the Joe Rogan experience that's next
that's next for decriminalization
mushrooms yeah that's next they're gonna
make that happen
they're gonna make it happen it's
already decriminalized in Colorado my
friend shot Evans was here yesterday he
was talking about it I think they're
gonna pull that off in California as
well they have to they just even from
micro dosing if we could just get
everyone to microdose the world would be
so much better I feel like that's the
new trend right now I hear that all the
time yeah it was just like I just Micro
does it is my wrist I've done a bunch of
times I know I know someone who micro
doses acid I'm like [ __ ] a lot of guys
in Silicon Valley just crazy and they
think it keeps all their negative
chatter at bay I had a buddy of mine
who's just here the other day micro
doses he says he takes it every three or
four days that's his thing no no
mushroom mushrooms like the little
capsules little pills they grind it up
the father grind up the mushrooms and
he'll take one capsule every three or
four days and it keeps he said just
keeps negativity out of his head keeps
me positive keeps them healthy yeah that
makes sense
yeah a lot of fighters are into it now
yeah I feel like that's what they did
with with weed it's like I just feel
like especially now in California just
feel like more people are just kind of
chill with it
yeah I mean I just remember like I can't
even go back to like back in the day of
like I got a joint let's go smoke in the
car on Shh shut up shut up
cars driving by look especially if
you're traveling yeah yeah Joey Diaz is
a famous film of we went to Austin Texas
and Joey Diaz used to hide the limit and
his balls and he's on the Alex Jones
Show talking about a hides weed under
his balls and it's there now it's
probably stuck there so probably forgot
about it but he used to that's what he
used to do is take a little baggie put
his weed in the baggie zip it up and
tuck it under his balls in his underwear
ah that's crazy no you had to you had to
be careful yeah I knew guys that would
put it in coffee yeah yeah coffee then
now you just have a bag of gummies and
you're like whatever didn't even know
what it is I mean how many people
exactly you know so guys a vape pen oh
yeah cool they don't check they don't
give a [ __ ] they're just looking for
bombs hmm and as it spreads across the
country the the legality
think it's legal state legal in what
nine states something like that and then
medically legal and like 18 or something
how many let's find out let's how many
states
let's try Siri I think it's uh I'm gonna
say nine states legal
I'm gonna go 18 states medical okay is
that right Jamie let's find out I think
look at that whole [ __ ] all those green
the dark is enabling the dark is legal
yeah and the father other ones or what
medical yeah so everything's medical
well Texas isn't I know I don't think
Texas is what is Texas Tech so detects a
like Texas Texas get to Texas as a light
green is nothing medical CBD oil CBT
yeah decriminalize no well he's taking
it CBD CBD is the gateway cuz that [ __ ]
is so good for them see it's a gateway
that is the gateway I know they have it
in everything now hand cream eyedrops
medical yes medical no decriminalize no
so the light ones are what go to light
ones are fully illegal and what's
Tennessee's tennis I have family in
Tennessee fully [ __ ] yeah white ones
are fully [ __ ] we don't sneak around
in Tennessee what is up in those green
ones up north let's Wayne what is this
the squares the squares the light the
light ones down oh the yellowish ones
yeah what is that Wyoming no medical no
decriminalized what is the one next to
Wyoming what is that state right next
left left Idaho I don't know yeah see
that's how they keep people out
cuz Colorado man when they made it legal
in Colorado [ __ ] everybody move there
yeah they did Colorado boomed of course
they're real estate jumped tremendously
they started making a shitload of money
I think Hawaii's got it like weird too
this is mixed yeah what does it say okay
so it's reduced penalty and then Alaska
is like free right yeah legal powerful
friends in Alaska that's crazy it is
crazy but look that just what we're
looking at there Massachusetts legal
main legal Vermont Vermont lega
what is that Illinois is New Hampshire
still illegal what is New Hampshire
medicine all I never do this so I don't
really care they're just like Austin you
know they're just like we're in Texas
but we're cool but New Hampshire is
weird because that's supposed to be live
free like their bumper stickers or their
life alert diehard notice live free or
die
yeah and Florida is what medical so
there's really only a few backwoods
states
well the Florida bath salts are fine so
one two three four five always worried
because it's fully legal in DC and
that's a not a state or a thing that's
the federal government city but it's not
legal put that cursor off the state so I
can count them one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
twelve states fully legal over legal so
what you say nine
I said nine or twelve that's good that's
progressive yeah
[Applause]